you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast best practice criteria
for pluripotent stem cell lines and
Kristy jewel of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth and
sponsored by stem cell technologies for
more information on our sponsor click on
the sponsor logo at the left side of
your screen now let's get started I
would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type the
minute II ask a question box and click
the send button also please notice you
can share this webinar on your personal
social media just click on the social
sharing tab on the left to let your
friends and colleagues know about
today's live event now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or use that ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce today's presenter
Lynne Healey principal laboratory
research scientist human embryo and stem
cell unit at the Francis Crick Institute
in London for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen Lynne
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Christy for that introduction
today I'd like to talk about best
practice criteria for pressing stem cell
lines so the aim of this webinar is to
understand why quality control is
central to best practice to be aware of
tests available for the quality control
of cell lines and to be aware of the
consequences of not performing quality
control testing so what is quality
control well the quality control of cell
lines measures the consistency and
ensures that the lines using an
experimental setting are actually fit
for the purposes that they're intended
for every time we use them though this
is achieved by testing the lines for
physical and functional attributes
against a predetermined set of criteria
thereby demonstrating that these
attributes are consistently present now
this type of testing promotes robust
reliable reproducible science and as we
know this is very key to good research
quality control of human protein stem
cells is achieved through best practice
and first to understand how this evolved
we really need to go back to the
beginning so if we go back to 1998 when
you an embryonic stem cell lines were
derived we can see that this for 17
years after Mouse es cell lines were
derived and in this instance in 1998
five cell lines were originally derived
now they were growing in media
containing inactivated mouse feeders and
they were the same media as you would
grow mouse embryonic cells in so
basically people just took the mouse
system and adapted it to the human cells
however if we look at this first paper
it does tend to set out the basic set of
criteria that characterizes human
embryonic stem cell lines and these are
morphology cell surface markers teratoma
formation and in vitro differentiation
and also very very important karyotype
so if we look at the morphology of
undifferentiated cells what do we what
do we see well we look we look we tend
to look for colony features and these
colonies around compact flat
well-defined and have smooth edges the
features of the cells within those
colonies have a high nucleus to
cytoplasm ratio they've got prominent
nucleoli never scant cytoplasm and
they're small around now this is the
general thing that we see but as some of
you know who might work with
dissociation reagents whereby you make
single cells you're often find that you
might get a lawn of cells rather than
the colony for morphology however as all
of us know that work with human
embryonic stem cells or prepotent stem
cells we tend to find that we look at
the cells on a day-to-day basis and this
morphology is key to how we identify
undifferentiated cells
what about stem cell markers well we
tend to use the same markers originally
described for embryonal carcinoma cells
and these are today's pacific embryonic
antigen markers three and four
Trafalgar one sixty into Fargo one
eighty one and these have been
consistently used to the beginning for
the identification of the embryonic stem
cells we've also looked at a nonspecific
alkaline phosphatase which comes up and
is positive on these cell lines
now one of the gold standards for the
definition of human number and extensors
is the fact that they conform teratomas
in immunodeficient mice and these are
tumors that have representation of all
three germ layers in them and this
demonstrates bra potency and the other
way we can demonstrate that the cells
have this capacity to form the different
germ layers is by in vitro
differentiation and in this original
paper we had examples of both we had a
very limited in vitro differentiation to
ectodermal trophoblast cells but we had
very very good teratoma formation and
you can see these showing some cell
lines in the in the photo that's on this
slides you can see the different types
of structures that you find when you
when you do a teratoma formation
karyotyping now karyotyping is very very
important something that often gets
neglected because it's quite expensive
to do now when these cells are rigidly
developed it was G binding that was the
main thing that people tended to use for
karyotyping again another gold standard
now the resolution of G binding isn't
particularly good but it can detect
whole and partial chromosomal
aneuploidies it can detect mosaicism it
can detect both balanced and unbalanced
transportations but it requires a
specialist training and knowledge to
prepare the song because interpret the
results and the turnaround for this can
be lengthy so if you're not if you don't
happen to have a carrier typing service
within your institution you have to send
alfred or or utilize a clinical care
typing service you can often take awhile
to actually get your results back
now if we look about look at the
generation of cells with time we found
as we said in 1998 we had five cell
lines by 2005 that had grown to 414
human embryonic stem cell lines then in
2007 we had a new kid on the block we
have the human induced pluripotent stem
cells appearing and if we come up to
current times now in 2020 if you look on
the Hester age registry you can see the
767 cell lines and 2303 prepotent stem
cell lines induced pluripotent stem cell
lines so if we think about this this
means that we needed to get some sort of
criteria to be able to compare lines
with each other so we pour this
standardization but why do we
standardize well it's basically because
we needed consensus for best practice in
an area of interest
we need this to enable consistency
comparability and to be able to deliver
reliable reproducible robust processes
so we need well characterized starting
materials and derivatives
now this comparability of cell lines is
very very important because it provides
us with common standards for research
and development and it's extremely
important for repositories when they're
banking cells because they're going to
provide feedstocks of with educators and
well characterized cells to researchers
and they need to show that these cell
lines are sharing common characteristics
and properties so we're all working with
the same with the same type of cell
again this transverse oscillation
becomes very very important when you're
looking at large infrastructure projects
especially involving industry and farmer
where you've got to show again the
comparability with different testing
using different types of propos and stem
cell lines and this is evident in big
big infrastructure processes such as the
humanities proposing stem cell line
initiative the embryonic stem cell based
novel alternative testing strategies
stem Bank European bank fringes
proposing stem cells and also big
projects where they've been looking at
repeated dosed systemic toxicity testing
to replace animal testing and this is
where human induced pluripotent stem
cells have come into their own because
there's lots of them have been generated
and they they are now becoming a
standard for certain types of testing
you
so how did this pro potent stem-cell
community reached his consensus well in
2003 the International stem cell forum
was made up and it comprised 21
countries though the aim of this forum
was a concerted global effort between
scientists clinicians regulators
suppliers ethicists call facilities or
to address issues around proponents
themselves so this is quite a large
number of people all involved in this
because they could see how important it
was to have certain standards in place
now this forum looked at four main areas
ethics intellectual intellectual
property standardization and banking now
from the standardization point of view
the International sense of initiatives
was the the main body to do that and
this was an expert working group
developing a global set of standard
criteria for the derivation
characterization and maintenance of the
cell lines
there are actually three stamps and
initiatives that have taken place within
the international stem cell forum the
first one the ski one was started in
2005 and there was a publication that
came out in 2007 and this looked at
antigen and gene expression patterns in
human embryonic stem cells the second
initiative is key to was a comparison of
Culture Media and genetic changes that
occurred during prolonged growth of
human ES and IPS cells and there were
publications in 2011 and 2010 Fitness
and the final project was sp3 which is a
development of consensus protocols for
assessing pure potency and this was in
2018
now these initiatives were set up by
this group of people to actually explore
areas of interest and concern for
researchers and they have come up with
quite a few interesting things if we
look at the first one if we look at sp1
this publication actually involved
looking at 59 human embryonic stem cell
lines from 17 laboratories and even
though the cells were grown under
different conditions you still found
they had very similar expression
patterns for example the SSE a three and
four twelve one sixteen four one eight
one the alkaline phosphatase were all
identified as being the key marks that
we needed to use and SSE a1 which in
Mouse in the mouse es lines is positive
for the undifferentiated cells is
positive in the human cells when they're
differentiated so traverses we also
looked at 96 genes that were 96 genes to
characterize these cell types 2 and nano
an acht for obviously came up as being
very very key genes to look at the lines
weren't identical however you saw
several lineage markers that were
evident and and different and
imprinted genes some female lines
Express regular detectable levels that
exists whereas others didn't but other
another thing that was looked at was
mycoplasma and bacteria inside perfect
viruses and really within that cohort of
cells we didn't really find any of these
so that was a very that was very vague
because it shows that those good
practices going on in each of the
laboratories that submitted the cells so
we poison white the plasma testing so
important well Mike replies were very
small bacterias with no cell wall and
they often introduced in cell cultures
via cell cultured components and they
can actually pass through through the
point 2 micron filters using mycoplasma
contaminated cultures and experiments
calls into question the validity and
significance of any research generated
so what effect this might surprise were
actually have well it can affect cell
metabolism it can affect cell
performance and it can affect viral
activity and infectivity of viruses so
it's very very important that you test
for mycoplasma it's one of the
fundamental things that you should
always be doing because if you bring
cells in from outside your laboratory
you don't know what you bring in with
them so you must always consider that
mycoplasma testing is being of prime
importance
now as we said when in 1998 the first
human ear cell lines were devised they
were derived on Mouse inactivated mouse
feeders and one of the promises of human
ear sciences for therapeutic treatments
so with this in mind we had to try and
move away from using things like mouse
feed is to try and develop feeder
through systems and we went through a
sort of a system where we have echo
cellular matrix proteins such as gel
treks and Maitre gel then we've gone
through some synthetic things where
we've made recombinant versions of
proteins and now we look it much more
defined media where everything is fully
synthetic and this isn't the spin moving
quite rapidly through systems and with
the help of a number of suppliers who've
worked very very closely with the
scientific and clinical communities to
try and achieve this
so if we look at feeder food culture at
the moment we've got quite a number of
different media we've got teaser which
which is really the most popular we've
also got teaser Plus now which will
enable you to not have to feed the cells
so frequently because it's got um the
fgf has been more stabilized in it we've
got very basic media like eh essential 8
which only has a few components in it
and teaser yet which is very similar
media we've got stem flex which again is
another media that allows you to not
have to feed so so frequently and we've
got nutria stem and for some of these as
GMP versions and these are for clinical
application we've also got differences
in the substrates we've got fit Renekton
we've got laminin we've got synthamax
which is really a form of a fit Renekton
we've got matric gel and we've got gel
tracks so we've got these different
substrates to go with these different
media and on top of that we've also got
different ways of passing the cells we
can passing them enzymatically or we can
passage them with rodents like EDTA or
EVC a based reagents so that they are
not so harsh when you're actually
passing the cells and it also depends
whether you want to plump passage the
cells or whether you want to make them
sing or so now if you want to make them
single so most people will add Rock
inhibitor into it because that increases
the survival of the single cells
so the ec2 publication compared defined
culture systems for feeder free
propagation of human embryonic cells now
at that stage there was an um still a
number of um
feeder fee culture systems that had been
developed but a lot of people were also
making their own in-house homebrews of
things and when we compare this thing
that came up was the fact that em teaser
and stem Pro consistently functioned
well in the asses of growth in stem cell
maintenance throughout all the studies
whereas a lot of these um other home
brews fell along the wayside I think
this is due to the fact that if you do
buying commercial media it's always
being to seed for you and you know that
it should you shouldn't get back as much
to batch but variability as you would do
with your home brews where you're buying
in all your own individual components so
I think that taught us that it was very
very key to work with the commercial
media
the other thing that has been noticed
right from the more-or-less the start of
working with these cells was that you
could get genetic aberrations occurring
as you were culturing them and these
were often chromosome 12 and 17 and
promo's m12 is obviously involved in the
embryonal carcinoma cells and so you see
sort of similar things to that and over
time you are seeing more and more of
these things arising in cell cultures
and
t-too they decided to look at the
genetic changes that occurred off when
they prolong winter on culture and 125
human embryonic stem cell lines and 11
IPS lines and 38 laboratories who looked
at this time and most were analyzed at
early and make passage there was snip
analysis and there was and we found that
most lines remain carry typically normal
but there was a tendency to acquire
changes on foreign cultures commonly on
112 from those 112 17 and 20 there were
no common variants relates to culture on
chromosome ones and 17 but minimal
amplicons on chromosome 20 including 3
genes genes expression ES cells were
detected and one of these was BC l2 l1
and that's a strong candidate for
driving culture adaptation in ES cells
and with time and looking more and more
you see papers popping up discussing
these recurrent changes that you
actually see with the cell culture so at
the moment we sort of know that we've
got loss of 82 gain of X 1 2 8 12 P 17
to 20 and 22 and why cell have been
doing fantastic job at recording and
keeping analyzing a lot of the samples
that they get in to do karyotyping on G
banding on and they have been looking
for trends and it's been quite difficult
really to to get to grips with whether
the trends are related to some of the
changes in the cell culture media and
things like that because they don't
always get those sorts of datasets going
in but they're constantly updating this
de set of data to see if they can
determine any trends
so bearing in mind that we're saying how
key how important these character
pictures are if you talk to the majority
of scientists most of them don't tend to
do karyotyping very often so it's very
very good to see that the suppliers have
sort of tried to come to our aid and
develop rapid testing little kits that
we can use so a targeted to those
specific changes that we've discussed so
here we've got one from stem-cell
technologies and that's based on this
paper that came out from Ivana barbaric
from Peter Angie's lab where she looked
at these are driving at these mutations
and seeing how you could actually
develop a way to test for them so
there's a PCR method that's a qPCR
method that we can use to look at this
select cohort of chromosomal
abnormalities we've also got some that
really come up where people are looking
at digital droplet PCR which of course
those of you that are doing gene editing
know is quite an important thing to - an
important piece of apparatus to use and
this will keep an eye on how this
develops as well from the point of view
of rapid testing
one of the other things that people are
doing is some are moving away from the
traditional G banding and looking at
molecular karyotyping and some companies
have got some quite good systems for
doing that and they're much more
sensitive than you find with the G
banding however there are limitations
because they don't detect balanced
transportations and at the moment a
number of groups are using carrier
status A's but also cytosine it be chips
as well to try and have a look at these
changes and see if they can detect them
faster because it's been a faster
turnaround it's still a still relatively
expensive but a faster turnaround than
perhaps some of the G banding has so
alongside with these genetic aberrations
people are finding that there are
mutations arising especially in things
like p53 which is if you think about
using the cells in a clinical setting
you want to be aware of these types of
mutations because a lot of these are
related to cancer mutations and they've
been identified in a number of different
types of Pro potent stem cells now so if
you're thinking along these lines you
should consider things like targeted
sequencing and next-generation
sequencing based assays to actually get
a more in-depth look at what's going on
with yourself however as you know when
you when you look at this type of thing
it's only a snapshot because as you go
on to treat the cells under other
conditions you might introduce other
types of changes of the cells as well
the next study that st produced was
development of consensus protocols for
assessing pro potency now people had
been using as you said the teratoma
assesses the gold standard
yet a lot of groups and a lot of
companies surprised had also developed
in vitro assays for looking at
differentiated cells looking at products
from the three germ layers so we really
wanted to know whether teratoma these
were really something that we had to
still keep as our gold standard and we
looked at the assessment of established
techniques to determine developmental
and malignant potential of human Pro
potent cells and we found that one of
the test protests which is a sort of in
silicon test which would predict Pro
potency so we didn't necessarily have to
perhaps use the gold standard teratoma
assay for in vitro differentiation if we
actually did this very simple
differentiation of the cells that we
were working with we could look at using
a scorecard panel and this would assess
the pro potency of cells or the cells at
the start of the differentiation and
what happened after you've done the
trial lineage differentiation and this
was done using real-time qPCR and this
is this is very good for for assessing
that type of activity because again it
means you're not necessarily having to
use a teratoma
however the teratoma assays are very
good at predictable for safety assay
because they can predict malignant
potential and that's relevant to pre
clinical safety assessments so there's
different assays depending on what you
want to actually look at so at the end
of that at the end of this the paper the
publication that came out we suggested
different types of assays depending on
your application and that's summarized
in this slide here
the other thing as we said is the
tumorigenesis II of the cells and people
are found again within with culture
adaptation that you're finding that
you're getting some tumorigenic
potential coming up in these cells you
want to try and and minimize that so we
want to be keep looking at how we're
treating the cells so as I said before
we use single cells will often treat
them with Rock inhibitor and one of
these papers are shown the rock
inhibitor actually activates pathways
which are involved in teratoma formation
so we need to be very aware of what
we're actually doing with the cells and
we need to try and minimize the
tumorigenic potential and paper by gene
Lorentz group they've actually looked at
guidelines for minimizing tumorigenic
potential for cells to be used in cell
therapy and there's a little table here
to actually discuss what should be done
perhaps and as you can see the longer
time and culture is correlated with more
genomic alterations again enzymatic
pathogen is associated with more dynamic
aberrations
so we need to think about the way that
we're actually culturing these cells
because at the moment we're still all
picking our favorite ways to to culture
and going along with that and I think as
I said earlier we're not really thinking
so much about the karyotype which is
very important so where do all of these
sorts of consensus ideas spring from now
if we go back to good cell culture
practices this is what we need to sort
is how we build our consensus models
but cell culture practice guidance is
based on six operational principles the
first one is understanding your in vitro
culture system then looking at the
quality assurance of the system
documenting what you're doing so you can
say no how you derive the cells what
they've been cultured in since how many
pathologies are going through that sort
of thing what testing is done you want
to look at safety you know have you
tested the cells for adventitious agents
and things like that we need to comply
with ethics and legislation and one of
the fundamental things is to make sure
that the people who are doing these
assays have a solid training and that
training makes them fit for purpose with
respect to working with stem cells and
in 2017 the GCC P principals replied to
working with stem cells and stem cell
derived models so this is a very
interesting document to read because it
sort of lays out the do's and don'ts of
working with stem cells
now alongside the international stem
cell Bank the International stem cell
initiative with the International stem
cell banking initiative and again this
was based on good cell culture practice
and this brought out a number this
district information that was coming out
of the iski the iski papers and adapted
it brought it into the banking arena and
as we said earlier on for repositories
where they're doing stem cell banking
having this type of consensus is very
very key so the international Central
Bank initiative has brought out two book
two papers one in 2009 which was looking
at research grade cells and another one
which looks at cells for clinical
application
and if we look at a standard
characterization of the testings for the
generation of cell banks we see exactly
what we've been seeing coming out of
history we can see we can see the
bacterial fungal and mycoplasma testing
we can see the carrier type in there
we're asleep roy potency assays we can
see cell antigen expression so gene
expression and genetic stability we've
also got things like post or recovery
which is important if you're going to be
sending cells out to users you need to
make sure that you can recover them when
they when they take them into the
laboratories and start to thaws them and
also looking at growth characteristics
one of the other things on here is cell
line identity and that is a very
important thing and I'll bring that up
in a few in a couple of slides just to
discuss it so alongside that as we've
said the human induced pluripotent stem
cells have also been growing in numbers
and again their potential to use in the
clinic has become very very important so
accusing a quality control guidelines
for clinical grade human proponents stem
cell lines has also been derived I'm
sorry this is a bit like the slide looks
a bit small but if you look at the
criteria again they're the same as you
see for the standard characterization of
cell banks now as I said as I said a
couple of slides back cell line identity
is very important and it's it's along
with mycoplasma it's one of them is the
other important test it's the DNA
fingerprint for a cell line this uses
short tandem repeats to identify the
cell lines so when you derive a cell
line you should keep back some of the
original material make an STR profile
for this material which will generate a
reference profile to be used for the
future identification of this cell line
so this profile can be used to ensure
that your worth with the correct cell
line throughout the cell culture process
because for many years a lot of people
have found out using normal somatic cell
lines that they've actually not been
working this
they think they've been working on and
if you think to yourself about this a
lot of money has been wasted on in vitro
work where you've not been working the
state on the correct cell line because
your results don't mean anything because
you can't you have been working what you
thought you're working on so this form
of testing is very very important when
you start to do some in vitro work
because you want to make sure that
you're working with what you think
you're working with
so please alongside the mycoplasma
testing if you're doing any testing
please have these two uppermost in your
testing protocols so alongside the
banking the prepared sample has also
been used in toxicology so we looked at
standardizing these and these again are
using for this type of thing you're
looking at your starting material which
is equivalent to what you'd be having
from a bank and then looking at what you
want to actually differentiate these
cells into so you're going to look at
criteria that you want to set for your
endpoints
so something that's been very very
important and key to a lot of this
research has been a development of a
human proponent stem-cell registry which
is as amalgamated a number of registries
that had been in place earlier on
because as you can see there's so many
cell ones being generated and we need to
be able to go to some single point where
we can actually look at all of these
cells and see which cell lies we might
want to use in our in our research we
want to know if they've been sourced
ethically so there's a lot of things on
this website so if you go into it you
can register your cell lines where you
make your cell lines you can put their
characteristics in them you can put all
of the ethical documentation and if
somebody wants to go and use the cell
lines of the project all the
informations already here
for them to actually use so I'll
encourage I'd encourage you to actually
put your cell lines that you make onto
that because again it helps the
standardization and within that that
registry you can see the standards and
main creature for referencing
authentication of the proponent cells so
there's a tool there which shows you how
you should name your cells so that
you've standardized that another way we
can achieve standardization is through
automation because again this can
provide consistency in automate a
process to rule out operator error and
judgment however it can be expensive but
you could get some sort of a lesser you
don't have to have fully automate
process you could also make part of a
process such as feeding cells for
example
so another thing that you can think
about is using a high throughput system
which is pretty cost effective for
characterizing things like induced
pluripotent stem cell cohorts where you
combine a number of methods maybe you
might barcode some of the some of the
cells or some of the testing you can
look at sort of small subsets of markers
that will show you whether you've got a
consistent differentiation happening and
also looking at snip arrays for high
resolution digital carrier typing so
there's a number of different different
ways you can approach standardization
and characterization of yourselves so if
we look at the last slide here basically
we've discussed standard settings down
to criteria to characterize human ES C's
and IPS C's lines so as we said
authentication is primary Turnus
sterility testing especially mycoplasma
testing and pathogen testing morphology
now that's our de the assessment that we
do a selection of cell surface markers
teratomas if you want to if that's
something you need to do for your your
purpose of your of your of your workflow
in vitro differentiation using directive
differentiation and very very
importantly karyotyping yourselves which
you can do through a different a number
of different ways and I think if you try
and look at these basic sets of criteria
and can adhere to them then it will make
your science much more robust and
reproducible and at the end of the day
that's what we need to do to move the
field into clinical settings we need to
be able to ensure that we're maintaining
these types of standards thank you very
much for listening and I'd like to open
the floor to questions
Thank You Lin for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have any questions you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started we
have some great questions already coming
in then let's start with this one what
is the first thing a user should do when
receiving a new cell line
um well when you're receiving a new cell
line it depends how it's sort of coming
so if you're receiving them in a vial
rather than growing cells first of all
you want to put those cells straightaway
into liquid nitrogen to make sure that
they're stored safely until you start to
do your processing when you start to
grow the cells up you really should be
checking well if they've come with a
certificate of analysis repository you
should have things on there like
mycoplasma testing and as you're
profiling you should start off really by
doing those types of tests when you take
the cells up
thank you our next question now this
question is two parts what is the
recommended frequency of karyotyping for
pscs after how many passages and is
there a guideline for a maximum number
of passages to keep in culture of an
IPSC line I think the majority of us
would tend not to keep the cell line up
for more than 20 pathologies and we
would tend to as soon as we receive the
cells make banks of cells and then we
would test those banks with respect to
carrier typing in process basically it's
as you can see from the talk for things
like G banging that there's quite a long
turn around I'm often you will do
something like pass I say every 10
passages but you might be advised to
look more frequently if you can doing
say the rapid testing like this stem
cell technologies kit allow you to do
that quite effectively and efficiently
whilst you're doing the process but I
wouldn't keep ourselves up for more than
20 passages I then go back to a voyage
frozen down and start with those
when do you believe that long term use
of Rock inhibitor can have a negative
effect on cells well looking at the
literature I mean you could see from
that talk there was a paper that was
probably showing how it could affect and
selectively allow cells to grow through
however a recent papers just come out
from UM Peter Andrews lab and that and
they've been looking at using using the
rock and they haven't really seen much
of a difference with the rock being used
in in their system so I think
unfortunately it's very very difficult
because it also depends on the way
you're culturing yourselves you know
which matrices you're using which media
I think it's personally I'm not a great
lover of using rock too much because I
do worry that it might allow for
selection but I think it really depends
on how how you sort of culture
yourselves I think schools out on that
at the moment if I'm honest with you
Lyne regarding genetic mutations have
you ever considered to look for
mutations in the mitochondrial DNA
personally I haven't done that but I
know some people have done that but I
haven't used it as a standard practice
thank you are there additional defined
characteristics that you would use when
using IPS CS to model age-related
disorders
to be honest with you I'm not actually
in that area so I wouldn't necessarily
know but I can find out some information
and get back to you if you'd like on
that
very good and yes we do have her email
address so ok at work I'll do the get
back to Casas thank you do you think
that tri lineage in vitro
differentiation is an acceptable
alternative to the teratoma assay so I
think that if you look at the literature
that's out there and again depending on
what you're actually looking at I think
it probably is the thing about the
teratoma is that it's very good for
looking up sort of potential malignancy
and that I know it's the gold standard
and in the original consensus that we
wrote for looking at stem cell lines
when they were derived we did say that
it should be performed at least once
during the lifetime of that of that cell
line but I think things have moved quite
have moved along quite a way now and I
think people are more accepting in
looking at the the tri lineage
differentiation as being an acceptable
test but it depends what you want to
show is you know everything is context
dependent
really
how can we reduce the cost associated to
respecting good quality control
practices
this is a difficult one I work where we
are in our Institute we're very
fortunate in that we actually have in
half sir in-house testing for things
like mycoplasma and str profiling and
also for low pass sequencing to look at
carrier typing so I think you might have
to restrict down to what you think is
essential but I would definitely say
your mycoplasma your SQL profiling and
your carrier typing is definitely
essential things that you should be
doing consistently I think I showed on
slide four teeth at you could try and
minimize cost with us or a high
throughput type of characterization so I
think that's been something that's been
spoken about by a lot of institutions
where they're having to to monitor lots
and lots of cells so that type of thing
is much more efficient where perhaps
you're deriving your own panels of of
gene panels and things like that
so I think that's a way to go but it's a
very it's a very difficult thing again
it's a bit the context of what sort of
experiment you are doing as well because
you might have to put cost more and say
if you are doing differentiation
exclamation mass to put the cost more on
that side of it as well so it's really
looking at what you actually do need to
do to achieve the most consistent
results
Gulen what would you say is the
number-one thing holding PSCs back from
the clinic right now
hmm that is a very difficult question
really I think that we are quite fearful
of there being any aberrations within
those cells and we don't really want to
put something back into a patient if
we're not sure if it's going to be a
hundred percent um it's not going to be
you're really well characterized and
also we've got a lot of problems with
things like getting differentiation
working consistently so I think that's
one of the one of the problems really um
the regulator's the regulatory bodies
are trying to work very hard with the
scientific community and the clinical
community to push these things forward
but I think it's going to be I know it's
taking a long time and we hope to all of
this up years ago I think we are getting
there and I think one of the main things
is safety which people are frightened of
but something might not be safe because
a few of the trials that started there
have been some when they've they've
looked at the cells they haven't been as
perhaps done as well as they thought
they might do I think we still have a
lot to do with safety concerns
very good thank you I'll leave so many
great questions coming in let's see try
to find some that are repeats here then
how do let's see with regard to marker
expression as a QC method most essays
that measure gene expression are
relative is there a consensus in the
field for what qualifies as enough
expression of these markers for example
quantification of these markers does
this require that researchers agree upon
the same control gene for all of these
assays so that they can compare the
relative expression across labs or is it
typically viewed as a binary measure the
IPC is either Express the markers when
they don't well I think a lot of people
are using a quantitative PCR for this
sort of thing rather than a yes-or-no
aspect to it um it's very difficult when
we did some of the original studies we
did put down all the all the values for
these different genes but as you say it
can depend when people are sampling as
well you know what stage during the
maintenance procedure that people solve
because obviously these things can
change I think that it's and I've really
answered this question well or not um it
would be nice to have some sort of
standard reference material for some of
these things so that would probably be
one of the first things and then I think
we do have enough data through from the
international stem cell initiative to
show that there is at this consistency
with this but we haven't necessarily got
an absolute cutoff for a CP value so I
think that's where you know that's where
our problems probably are with the
reference genes um often people will use
a panel of reference genes rather than
just using one or two housekeeping genes
just to show that in this you can see
some consistency through those so I
think that's the way that people are
actually going at the Moines that needs
to be something that's developed in the
possibly in the clinical and
translational setting when we get a
better consensus on this
very good Thank You Lin do you have a
good method for analyzing SNP area data
I personally don't so I am not really in
such a position to be able to help you
on that but I can go back and see if I
can find some information on that for
you
very good we'll make a note we have his
email as well okay good afternoon and
where could we get the G CCP anyway we
could have it for free as a PDF yes we
can I can um I can send you around the
link to it and what you want the GCC P
for these stem cells because that's the
one that you think you're probably are
wanting at the moment and I can I can
send that out so you've got it as a link
and you can just download it because as
far as I'm aware it's free to download
Thank You thing which surface coding is
best for maintaining pluripotency
ooh
really difficult one at the moment I
think from having sent cells off and
looking at them in protest a lot of the
a lot of the actual coatings seem to
enable the cells to maintain their prior
potency so I think again it depends on
what you're actually asking I don't know
whether anything has a bias I haven't
come across anything as someone having a
bias towards one or another lineages
from that point of view so I would say
at the moment probably most of them are
okay to use for proposing CSA's I do
like laminin though but that's just
something that um you know because that
seems to be very promising but I think
that in general we can use most coatings
that we've got going with the respective
media that they come with and still
maintain the poor potency
next question is two parts how many
passages can be performed on hip cells
before starting - for differentiation
and do you suggest to check the quality
of hip cells before starting the
differentiation process
definitely always have you always know
what your starting material is before
you start the differentiation process
because I think the problem with that is
if you start off with a bad quality I'm
starting material when it's going to
affect your reproducibility next time we
do it and - it's not going to give it
probably the results that you want from
it for having an uncultured now you've
got to remember that with some of these
cell lines are quite variable to begin
with and they're not completely settled
down for you for a number of pathologies
so I wouldn't probably start too early
on with them but I think people that are
doing gene editing like to start with
early passage early derived IPS CS but I
probably would wait till they're a bit
more settled down and and that there's
no sort of genetic variability with them
before I start
I'm not really home sorry I go ahead I
say I don't do so much of the
differentiation if I'm honest with you
so I'm not so I'm probably a starting
material girl rather than anything else
so I can chat again to some of my
colleagues and see what they recommend
and get back to you on that
Thank You Flynn and I was just wanting
to mention we have time for a few more
questions but do want to remind our
audience that those questions we are
unable to answer live today and any of
those that come in during our on-demand
period they will be answered by our
speaker via the email address you
provided at the time of registration to
have time for just a few more questions
Lyn our next question Thank You Lyn for
this great talk I have a question
regarding SNP analysis is there a common
ground on the threshold of deletion
sized duplications that are allowed for
yourself to be kept in culture
right so again as I sort of said earlier
I'm not focused on the analysis side of
these we often send our stuff off-site
to have it tested so we come back and it
will tell us whether things are
acceptable whether they've passed or not
so I'd have to go back and ask some
people and get some more information on
this but I can get back to you on that
there you get him again we have their
email address and what would you expect
IPS sees cultured in an e 8 formulation
to be of a different quality then those
cultured in mts r1 mt e sr + or stem
flex
okay so I would say that realistically
speaking the mts are the formulations
that are very rich they'll probably be
more sympathetic to yourselves so when
you feel you need to pass out yourselves
you've probably got more flexibility
with the rich images and you do with the
meters that don't contain such a rich
formulation so the essential aides and
things like that when you see yourselves
need to be split they need to be split
at that stage whereas you might have a
bit more give in the other majors so I
think that's really one of these sort of
differences you've got to be very you
know because you've got you're watching
those cells all the time and one
deterring them and I think the richer
meters will keep the sellers in a better
condition slightly longer that's just my
personal opinion
Thank You linen will wrap with this
final question can you summarize the PSC
QC procedures routinely performed in
your lab
okay so we will tend to do so we
mycoplasma test at least we do that
every month consistently and we will
karyotype the cells when we've taken
them up from frozen and during some of
the processes while we're sort of
culturing them for experiments we will
also send off the cells when we're doing
derivations for protests we're going to
start using school code we haven't used
that yes at the moment and we will also
grow the cells in broth to make sure
that they haven't got it because we
don't grow cells with any antibiotics
and to make sure that they haven't got
anything any bacteria or fungi or yeast
in them and when we've got newly derived
cells who are sending them listening the
original samples off for viral panels to
make sure that they haven't got any
adventitious agents into them
so our main things that we're doing at
the moment is the carrier typing
mycoplasma testing and so we type in
mycoplasma testing and str profiling
so that's what we do routinely as we're
keeping the cells in culture
Thank You then now before we go I do
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions again those questions we did
not have time to answer live today and
there were quite a few and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by land via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration I would like to once again
thank Lynn Healey for her time today and
for her important research we'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
stem cell technologies for underwriting
today's educational webcast another
reminder today's presentation is
educational and it does offer continuing
education credits if you are interested
in receiving your credit please click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits this
webcast can be viewed on demand and you
may continue to submit questions during
that on-demand period and lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon stay healthy and have a
great day